boule car podcast
with the legend big u is here what's up
man
thanks for having me thank you for
coming i feel like it's long long
long overdue man yeah yeah yeah i ain't
really doing a lot of interviews until
up until right now yeah you got um you
know
this i watched yesterday i went to uh to
uh mel's diner in um
sherman oaks and and watched the first
was it the first full episode or was
that two episodes that was only one
it goes so fast right it was only i said
only episode one
so this fx show it's it's hip-hop
uncovered right
hip-hop uncovered yes sir hip-hop
uncovered it follows um
you and four others um as kind of
behind the scenes factors in hip-hop now
for people who
um aren't familiar with big you
i think that if people were to just
google big you they're like okay big you
is a bit a gangster from l.a
i don't wanna i don't wanna put nothing
on you dad you know what i'm saying on
camera
but um you know explain to
to the people who aren't familiar with
who you are what you do kind of like
why is there an fx show that is centered
around you
man we pitched this show jimmy jimmy
chris came to me
uh four years ago with the idea for a
show and that's at the time that
everybody was
starting doing shows and um um
the etf hit the um
was that loving hip-hop it hit real big
so everybody was trying to get shows
and i had already done like several
documentaries what people don't know
about me
is how much work i have done in film and
projects
and i had i i wrote and co-acted and
acted in um
force of execution with veeam reigns um
danny treyo and uh steven sego i
i co-wrote that with with the guy i got
banged out of that didn't get my credits
but i did jam message a
turn two turn turns in the microphone
community i
produced several different films i
managed veeam reigns
for like seven seven eight years from
baby boy
so it's just a lot of people never knew
the work that i'd done
and so when i present projects it's
crazy because uh
filmmakers are excited to see big u
rap music is scared to see their own is
he gonna rob us
is is he is he out to get something and
it's crazy because i'm i'm more
comfortable
in the in the in the area of making
tv shows and projects because i can go
in the room with
filmmakers and people who produce in
that area
and they see me as a story they see me
as like they should be like yo
you can have a mini series right yeah
yeah and that's and their thing is that
but if i go in with mute people who do
music it's the
oh he's the blue [ __ ] intimidation thug
or he's coming to rob us and they don't
understand that
i make most of my money producing shows
and that's even doing concerts
and so that's what
helped me get this done because people
seeing a vision
yeah i think uh it was like overdue i
remember
i think i want to say me and head were
talking about it maybe like a year or
two ago just like
when is the big you like netflix show
coming
not even like a documentary like someone
plays you you know what i'm saying and
like
just follows you through your life and
[ __ ] like but you mentioned
people like on the rap side of things
like
you definitely have a stigma like you
said
when it comes to the hip hop world
people they might be intimidated or they
might be like oh [ __ ] if big use around
like what's going on type [ __ ] yeah um
talk about your i mean obviously for
people who don't know man i mean we'll
get it we'll get into all of that but
you know you you
found nipsey uh what was that oh four oh
three oh
oh no i came home no you came home 104
so it was like oh five
oh six oh no oh seven was nipsy already
working with steve
no okay i brought steve on okay okay i
brought steve on i
so i come on 104 and you know for
um i met steve because steve at the time
was dating my wife's
niece okay so that's how i know steve
i i don't know steve from music i know
steve i bet i met him
in a music setting at a concert and i
didn't have no artists at the time
so uh i met steve he was kind of having
some kind of conflict with suga over
saying the n-word
and i came home with 2004. so when i met
steve
he was kind of standoffish like we're
like what's up i'm like what's up man
i'm big you he's like
all right it was like ready to go and
i'm like
what's up with that i had no clue about
you know
the n word of c because i wasn't bred to
the growing
uh on social media and all that [ __ ] yet
right and um so
that's how me and steve met and then he
called me
or reached back out to me after he
realized
that i was saying that my wife
he know he's he's dating my wife's niece
and they have been together for like
three four years
and then he was like oh wait a minute oh
man he was like man you [ __ ] music man
you don't want to give a [ __ ] do
something else
and i'm like yeah all right but then i
was messing with suge
so i had my run with suge for a while
and managing corrupt then when corrupt
left
sure that was early early on that was
early that was like in the early 90s
early 90s well you got locked up in 91
right now i got like 91
and then come back to 2004. so when did
you start working with corrupt that was
i started with corrupting 90
like 89 1989
like 89 90 i made corruption so that was
technically was that technically before
death row right
i was definitely before death row yeah
that's why i said the death row thing
wouldn't happen
and that and amongst other things and
then i had laquan
so actually my first artist wasn't
corrupt nor nipsey my first artist i
ever dealt with singularly was laquan
papilloquie he had a goal-selling album
at the time the b term okay okay and he
came to me
in the foxhole mall and asked me to
manage him
and he was about 15 or 16. he had a flat
top and he walked it to me and him
corrupt no no no no no okay laquan poppy
q kenny kingpin
he was the first one i ever dealt with
so he came up to you at the mall he came
up to me and the mall was like i mean i
want you to manage me and i'm like no
he's the first thing he said to me was
crazy he said hey you were from my
father right you big you i'm like
i don't work for your father i never
worked for your father who's your father
then he said mr green and i'm like oh
reverse that i have done work for your
father they have a great deal of respect
for your father
but his father was in the feds or on his
way to the fair we knew he ain't got pop
i was his i was his father's young boy i
was one of his fathers you know like
he called me like you handled some [ __ ]
for yeah and then now i'm seeing his son
and he he got this flat top face clean
and i'm like you got a song i ain't
never heard the song
and then when he right when he you know
when somebody tell you about something
now you start hearing it everywhere and
so and then i
he called me back came to my house
you're like man i'm gonna show you how
to do it
and i'm like well you got to show me
what the [ __ ] to do because i have no
clue on how to manage nothing right
none of that so then we start going he
started taking me his little um
shows going to his video shoes i was
going in and then
after a couple of months now i'm still
going in and out of town hustling
and his [ __ ] got even bigger so i would
see him when he came back to town
but then now i'm going i'm going to the
soda
getting my bread coming back and so i
was still messing with him
then after about no something happened
and my crew got hit so i was kind of
sitting at home and my broomfield came
to me
and was like i got a kid named corrupt i
want you to meet him
and so i had the bread at the time and
his brother had bread too but
he was like man come on bro that's when
i met her up and i started moving with
corrupt
and um it was kind of fast man so it was
like
it was like a labor of love but it had
me a corrupt relationship built because
to me
it was like i didn't know we even had a
relationship because
i really had done nothing for him i
wasn't planning on signing him
to my label to delicious entertainment
we actually never got to the paperwork
to even get it done
but it was like he was signed and so i
seen corrupt one night
going to go do a lick with the homies
you know going to go
i pulled him out the car i called lamont
he tells the story all the time
and that established us right and then
we would be in the garage clown every
va's clowning rapping
planning and it was crazy because
i got a letter i was on i was on my
sixth year
in prison and i got a letter
and it had three thousand dollars on it
so when you get your mail
they'll send you like sometimes they
even send your pictures first or they'll
send you a card that you got money
and they sent me the letter let me know
have money so i can go fill out my draw
so i got three thousand dollars and
nobody never sent me three thousand
dollars
and then i was on lockdown so i think uh
four or five days later pictures came
and it was no letter it was just one
thing in there
and it was like i love you and corrupt
no letter no nothing that was it and it
was just a gang of pictures
and i'm like damn so he sent you the
three bands he sent me three bands
some pictures so this is like 94.95
no this would have been 96 97.
so this was like i was already in like
because i wasn't at caliphate no more i
was at
what that was awesome it was like
they're 96 97 corrupts already uh you
know uh uh
established yeah cause it was before
wikifreaky came out
yeah that was after he left and did the
the answer thing and the corruption
right okay yeah you're right you're
right
so it was then he was still with devin
but that time dog food was already out
dog pound
it was before dog food okay okay because
he had got some money it was before so
when was that i think that was 95
95 yeah so that's when he said that's
when he hit me that's crazy and then he
then we came off lockdown and i called
my wife and my wife like did you get the
letter from ricky and i'm like yeah you
got the money i'm like yeah i went to
store and everything
and i'm like where are you at then i
called him and then shortly after that
he bought me a cell phone like he
i had like the first cell phone in
prison technically that was contraband
right yeah well hello
[Laughter]
that's a record label no by the way wait
what contraband no it's fine
um no so uh so you when you got out of
jail you said you were rocking with suge
yeah and so explain to me that because
because um you know suga is a very uh
a blooded yeah he's a he well no no he's
just a um
you know people people either have
amazing things to say about him
very polarizing you know what i'm saying
so when you got out
well when my little brother got killed
first my little brother got killed
okay at the studio with corrupt now
corrupt key rock and all them so
that kind of like sugar was in jail no
chick wasn't chill yet
i think he was that kind of like
pondered us together like with my little
brother like he was sure
because krupp wanted to go back to death
row he asked me can he go back
and should he go back and i'm like yeah
with your money and i said you can't
worry about everybody else bro
go back so that that's when he went back
to death royalty left entre
and that kind of pissed snoop and dazzed
him off i remember there was that
there was that double xl cover with
corrupt and
left eye was on it and should yeah it
was like it was like when corrupt like
went back what year was that [ __ ] i was
probably probably around the time we're
talking because it was a
it was like it was like the new i think
it was when crooked i was rolling with
death row and [ __ ]
yeah see because i wasn't i had kind of
was in transition at that time then i
went to the hole
i did three years and nine months almost
four years in the shoot so i didn't have
nothing i didn't see no
from i think i got on two i got january
2004 so we go back
four years from near is when my life
stops
what did you um if you don't mind
sharing what what what did you end up in
the hole for
um i knocked somebody eye out it was a
conflict and
and we had altercation and his and his
eye came out
all my cousins are in prison and i've
i've been
thoroughly educated on how mentally
exhausting being in the hole can be
can you kind of like give us some of
that because like i know because for
people who don't know it's 23 hours a
day lockdown no
it's 24 hours a day because the way
corcoran shu did it was
you couldn't it was so many people in
the shoe that you couldn't get your
you couldn't get your one day out to
shoot it was too many bodies so they
would make you wait
and like you start the sales and then
you would get eight hours out to seal
one day a week and that would count for
your
so-called one hour after sale a day wow
so and then we would be we would be in
these um
we would we would be in these uh dog
kettles so
they had lined up a bunch of dog kettles
up and down in a row and
they put the little toilets in there so
you go in there they put all inmates in
there
just in your drawers your shoes you
can't take nothing else out and you sit
out there for
eight hours and they come get you take
you back bring out another group for
eight hours so it's
i guess they started that [ __ ] like four
in the morning well having
you gonna be out there from four in the
morning till whatever time for eight
hours or so
that's how it was was that it's crazy
because we always hear about like
you know you're supposed to rehabilitate
in prison that's what they say no the
california
california dropped that philosophy um
when i was incarcerated still like they
removed rehabilitation off all
california state prisons it's just
straight punishment it's just no
it's just incarceration they used to
when i came in two when i came in 2000
when i came in 1990 91 they said
some of the prisoners said
rehabilitation centers but they removed
that when they remove
education like they don't offer
education no more like you can't get
your ged in jail anymore no you can get
the ged that's the only thing you can
get they used to offer
higher education you can go to college
get your college courses you can't do
none of that now only thing they offer
is things that's conducive to
making money for the prison so the most
the thing that makes the most money for
california prison is optical
and you can only get that at san diego
and one other place so you may if you
get there you can make enough money to
send home
that's crazy well let's get back to so
suge knight you got out you know four
how did you and suge end up because
corrupt was at death row
okay so just by the way so yeah but
naturally you're out corrupt looking out
for you because you know you looked out
for him
however many years ago yeah and then on
corrupts there i come home
of course i got to go home i'm asked for
corrupt
and then me and sugar had already been
talking since my little brother had
passed before that
and so naturally when i come home i
messed with him
and i didn't want to be because it was
such a it was such a talk when
you know big use coming on the big [ __ ]
is coming home and all listen so
i i wasn't on that that's not where
where i've been
you know like i didn't want to come home
and say i'm i'm i'm going to
enhance the [ __ ] card and now i didn't
want to come home and do that i want to
come home
and be a muslim and be a man and be
somebody who could be conducive to us as
a people to move forward
and the mood is gender and so i feel me
dealing with should
would be stronger in making uh making a
unified
unity than going against because i
already had a relationship my homeboys
was which
my homeboys were with um my homeboys
were already with
snooping me big d was big d and was
already with uh snoop
so i just needed to go and establish
a relationship for all of us to be
together
and so when i did that it is
that's dwane it was called them all for
me and so
when i did that i wanted my sons to see
that you don't have no enemies there's
bloods
you know i mean and it was important for
me to bring
bloods and everybody around my sons and
around my community so they can see
we can be unified and that was the key
to what
what i've always been doing i've always
pushed that
before you know moving you know what i
mean so
sugar was important to me being able to
move as a man and being able to show the
people that
i'm not on no crippling blood [ __ ] right
and and what you said like when you got
out you were trying to be on some like
community [ __ ] and i think you've done a
good job of that man
it's crazy because i feel like you were
probably in jail for probably
at least the beginning or peak of when
the gang banging culture became like
commercial
as far as like i was in a shoe do you
like do you remember there was like a
bloods and crips
album i don't even remember that like
that was
it was like a real thing where it was
like it was really like
used to like propel record sales and
and it became second nature so like
you're in jail and you're like are you
like paying attention to how the [ __ ] is
blowing up
mm-hmm i did um
i i was watching because i was watching
the culture grow yeah and um
it's funny because before the east coast
west coast beef
you know it was it was it was the crips
and bloods trying to
the crips bloody album battle cat and
all them and then
at the time their uh my little brother
because you just had to get your music
sent in from the streets
back then and my little brother sent me
biggie smalls and wu-tang clan
oh wow and then he sent me all the other
stuff that i wanted so i was like
where the hell is biggie you all said
and i always was tripping off to album
cover because my little brother got a
picture like that
you got the baby baby door it on i'm
like ain't got the same [ __ ] so i
i had to i had the cd i never listened
to the cd
i never listened to biggie and i never
listened to um
and then we went on lockdown so my
homeboy who knew about them who had just
came to jail
he had the cds he was trying to get
rolled up he was transferring
so he gave me the cds back we're on
lockdown and i slapped in wu-tang
clinton
and that [ __ ] went crazy and so it's
like whoa tank clan
and i was like damn i slipped all these
dudes in the cream but
we was on lockdown so there's no
movement then i'm like man i slapped him
biggie
and i'm like this [ __ ] hard as [ __ ] yeah
and
that was like my introduction to the
biggie
i was at calapec state prison and i was
like damn
east coast is back on because the west
had had it had it for so long since like
the chronic
yeah yeah and let me tell you man it's
crazy because people always ask me how
long i've been amusing i was [ __ ]
music
i remember i pushed the ghetto boys in
l.a
okay or anybody else read these nikes i
was in minnesota
selling dope and one of my homeboys
one of my homeboys from minnesota it
gave me the tape
no i was listening to his tape and then
i was was in the car
and i was tripping out for every time i
read these nikes because that's all i
used to wear was nike's back then you
remember what number night like
nike adidas and converse yeah and there
was someone read these nikes and i
got hooked on ghetto boys i went home
and i dubbed i went there back and
dubbed the tapes that's when he used to
dub
i came back to la and i took all the
homies man the ghetto boys these [ __ ]
is hard
they blew up from there yeah you know
what i mean cause our music
if you remember if you remember back
then we was like
gang-banging to r b music yeah it was
like pop music
yeah i didn't even think like even like
la rap back then like
even like if you think before nwa was
like
iced tea yeah it was six in the morning
yeah it was you know like colors yeah
colors was
great yeah not it so
i wanted to ask you okay so the
perception
i think from the outside looking in is
like it would be a good idea
if you come to la to maybe tap in with
big u or to maybe check in with big you
is that something that is maybe a bit
amplified
yeah that's because because i feel i i
know that that's not the case
but i feel like that there is like you
know or at least some sort of
it's hella amplified but i feel like
certain people would be good too you
know what i mean like
especially from certain genders i think
certainly i think with when you from
certain genders you want to check in
with that gender
because well i get to question all the
time and like will
the influence well unfortunately la is
is
is influenced by gangs yeah you know
what i mean so if it's certain people
you need to check in with yg
whack 100 wacko there's certain people
need to check in with big u
you need to check in with tone you need
to check it with magic you need to check
in with
the twins from mature gangsters you need
to check it with certain people
who gonna help you know how to move in
different ways
who gonna let you know like you know
like these dudes what you claiming
and what you affiliated with they not
our enemies at this time but they could
be our enemies
in a day's noticing we don't even know
it but we know how to move around
you know what i mean so it's important
for me to have relationship with dudes
from every session a trades bloods
gangsters hoovers
all of that because we want to show
respect
and i and i feel like
people from all that says give me
respect because they see my history
they see my work ethic they see that
i've never
if my home wasn't wrong i'm gonna say my
homeboy wrong i'm not gonna side with my
own way right or wrong period point
blank
i didn't do them i don't do it with my
kids i teach my kids to do right and
wrong all right you know but i'm i'm
gonna support
truth and in prison and in 13 years
the dudes i did time with can come home
and vouch for that
you know i'm like no whatever he said
was he kept his word
so that's what i think gets me strength
in la
and the whole time i was with should we
never had one conflict
because i just didn't allow it you know
what i mean not that i could control him
but
you know sometimes you got to know how
to appeal to a beast right you know what
i mean like bro this we don't need this
i would always say like you know me and
had talked about this like if
if if you're somebody who's coming to la
and you come from that background from
wherever you're from it's probably a
good idea now maybe if you're like
maybe if you're like you know post
malone or r b singer or somebody you
know you're gonna get checked too
postman i'm gonna get checked too
all right i've been in there with
puzzling i've been in i've been in rooms
with posters that was just an example by
the way oh
i didn't know that he got checked by me
go tell the story i mean it wasn't about
me
i was just in the room when some dudes
wanted to get on post malone
and they was recording
and i happened to knew
notice know the people we was coming in
me and steve was doing something
and was leaving out it was my first time
ever meeting him
and sometimes people don't know you
could get i can squash [ __ ]
and don't even know and don't even say
nothing because it just was the timing
like
ooh you know what i mean because that's
just the mentality
of people man like it's never going to
change
because it's going to always be the
halves there's all the have nots
and it ain't even gang related
you you understand i'm saying because
you got gang members doing something to
their own gangs
in the name of money so it's not oh and
it's all and
they asked me the question about um um
hip-hop in the gangs in hip-hop well
there's always been gangs in music
we just don't we just see it now because
our music is the number one job do you
think back in the day like frank sinatra
had like my
time to say that yeah yeah we didn't
have mafia ties yeah mafia orders
right for sure this is what it is
because
anybody who's trying to make money the
easiest way to get in it is in this
music
like if you got money you want to put it
somewhere like we don't have no other
outlets that's what this documentary
talks about
hip-hop uncover talks about when
we were hustling and then we eventually
took that money to get into something
and try to do something positive
you know you might have a cousin or
auntie i'm a cousin or uncle a friend
who wants to do music okay what we need
studio time i got you
yeah you know and then it starts going
past that you start seeing the little
j's you start seeing the here you start
seeing the dudes making
making it and that's what hip-hop untold
is it talks about
us and our struggles in music you don't
hear about us
it's not it's not geared towards the
artist
it's geared towards the people behind
the artist like when i met you
like for instance if i had a new artist
right now like with osbs
my group osbs criticality i introduced
him and told them i called you to do an
interview with them yeah
i heard you was coming here that's
hip-hop uncovered that's when
that's why they call us the power
brokers because we already have the
relationships
when you first met nipsey nipsey met you
through steve
09. and me yeah he didn't have that
relationship with you right he couldn't
have called you
and and what people don't understand is
you need those power brokers
to help introduce you to people and then
those power brokers have to have a trust
in the relationship that comes from
somebody else
when i met philly phil i don't know we
could talk about him later it's all good
yeah and i met philly phil i met philly
phil and him and sugar was having an
altercation
at um um mel's diner
and i seen everybody going crazy and
sugar was coming and felly phil was
sitting in the restaurant
yeah and so me just not wanting to know
[ __ ] i go in i'm like i'm actually
phil like
i don't know i don't even know who he is
right at all i have no clue he was
and i'm like bro what's up with you man
it might he like nothing like
like he was shook i'm like i am and then
he's like man what's happening i'm like
i ain't nothing that i'm trying to ask
you what's happening like
jenny i said so who are you he tell me
i'm fairly filled
and i'm like so what's your problem with
should oh he mad at me because dj quick
dissed him on my show i said you got a
radio show like yeah
so i'm like i'll make no sense so i go
outside i talked to sugar i said bro why
you on dude here
and then they tell me man oh you know
what i'm saying
right like it's not common damn yeah it
ain't fairly far i tell phil man
gonna just leave feel like i'm not
leaving
i gotta talk to this dude man yeah like
i i don't i don't wanna walk outside and
see what happens
no no he wasn't saying that he was
saying he didn't want to leave
without talking to because he was like
man i ain't doing nothing to him
now i was like i was honorable to me
like i got a result gotta resolve it
yeah
man i ain't leaving i want to talk to
the dude and i said be sure
buddy but he kept it 100 so now i'm
moving right along
we signed nipsey i get that fairly fail
and i'm like bro i got a new artist can
you play the song
and that's how you those are
relationships
you see what i'm saying he played
bullets ain't got no name he played
another couple of songs for me
then he played with how we roll he
played this and then
so it's me taking my relationships and
connections
with with um my years in this industry
and putting it on another artist right
to become what he becomes and you've got
artists that come up 16
17 18 years old they don't know who to
talk to they don't know who to be
friends with
they don't know none of this stuff you
know what i mean and i had little homies
who didn't even want to do songs with
bloods
and i'm like nah bro you got to do the
song that's crazy
yeah now you i mean you think back just
like certain artists that like you're
like man they didn't like they didn't
work together
and it was just because of some politics
not even necessarily if they had any
personal issues
it was just there was some politics
involved and but and so
this documentary even when you go on the
dead you see your debt deal with french
montana
nicki minaj yeah but what did she have
to do
to get them to these levels to get what
did she have to go through to be able to
watch them through those doors she was
you know what i'm saying like she had a
history
that affirmed who she was to other
people
i have a history from the streets that
affirmed who i was
and people want to say it's about
bullying when it really isn't
it didn't have [ __ ] to do with bullying
they had [ __ ] to be people meeting me
and then them saying oh he ain't the
bully people think he is
he ain't the bully people make him out
i've come to
different people with songs and they
tell me that
that ain't gonna work i'm out to do it
let me go find another one
i've asked you all to do stuff yeah and
if it don't work it don't work
i'm never beating the door down i've
never beat you all door down no i'll do
this
but but if you hear it my that's my
reputation
like he's the bully he's this is that
and i and i'm like [ __ ] it i can't beat
it so i'm gonna join it like i guess i
am the bully
you talked about uh signing nipsey i
mean obviously
aside from being from the same area how
did you guys like how did that end up
you know happening um and you told the
story a lot
before so just kind of give us a quick
you know yeah uh
my my nephew td i was looking for
artists
td told me to go get nip i went seek
nipped out
out of all the people we had already i
already been interviewing and talking to
and he was the signing light he was the
diamond in a pile of whatever
right he was a diamond let me con
respect to my other homies he was a
diamond in a pile of other diamonds but
he just he just
he was a bigger diamond he was a design
yeah he was
and and then um he was the vvs he was
the vvs
yeah you know i said and
we had made a couple of moves and was
trying to move through a couple of doors
and i vastly found out
that i couldn't go through these doors
so that's when i went and got steve
lobel
and um i went and got steve let steve
hear the music
steve felt the same way i felt about the
music and
i was like boom so i assigned nissi to
unique music to my uh to um
to arie miss astrodome to my to my label
to unique music
and then steve was 10 percent management
and i was 10 percent managers didn't
make no sense
to go get another management right and
so we started pushing on that
so i signed him to it was signed to a
10-year production contract which
started in
2009 which would end 2019.
crazy hello but uh
i ain't tripping off of that because you
know it is what it is
but i do have that you know what i mean
wait so so your your deal with nipsey
was 10 years it was 10 years it was a 10
a 10 year 25 percent of publishing to
arie miss astronomy
oh wow so 09 to 2019.9 to 2019.
so technically victory lap hello okay
wow wow yeah help me okay
because when i first met nip was i met
him in 09 actually
this was when he was on the lax tour we
were on the lax tour
with the game and i think just sit you a
song on him before
well i became you know who put me on the
nip is charlemagne man
charlemagne he was doing radio in philly
and he was tweeting about
bullets ain't got no name volume one i
believe
i remember dm and charlemagne at the
time and that's who originally kind of
like i saw his [ __ ] and i was seeing his
[ __ ] on the blogs
like the now rights and two dope boys of
the world no that was late you already
met him before that
i met him in 09. yeah you had already
met him before that because he
we didn't officially finish the deal
assigning him
to but he had some [ __ ] out there like
on online
he didn't he didn't have nothing nothing
[ __ ] he didn't even know how to he
didn't even know how to upload the music
yet
you got to remember because well if i
met him if i met him in 09 so that was
the last yeah nothing out there nothing
he had nothing so he was on tour with
nothing out
no when he just i'm trying to tell you
okay before we did the gang
tour yeah we had already been messing
with nip
oh seven right right but i didn't meet
him until like that tour yeah
because even before the game tour he had
the song
with um with the tupac song
okay yeah on what was the pox life
he had pox life i got philly to put that
on the radio
that song started picking up all around
the country and
and park's mother had it pulled because
that wasn't the single they wanted to go
they had nipsy um they had nipsy
pock and um light skinny with the braids
from the east side
oh my [ __ ] gonna go crazy nocturnal no
no no no i don't know
chia beer man i got to call him chia
beer but anyway he gonna
talk about but yeah that song went viral
but even before that
we could just look it up actually
because yeah it was uh it was nitsy
tupac and um can't think his name
he's central he always got central like
crenshaw on his own
on his chest can't take his name but
anyway
that song was out and then even before
that before we even did the two it was
called seven international
what was the name of the song it was
young dre the truth
young dre the truth okay now look at
when that came out
this was
well this is on youtube so hold on let
me look it up
yeah but you gotta remember before that
we did i did him with the song with um
with uh snoop oh sex oh six
yeah and that wasn't even the first song
we did snoops
i did him with snoop and um nip this new
uh gangster's life yeah see i i didn't
really start i think the first project
that i really tapped in was
burlington got no name the first one
right and then like i really became a
fan the second one i think he had to um
roll the windows up [ __ ] was so hard but
that was later that was like 2010 i
think yeah all that was late
yeah yeah well i was late but i met him
in 09 he came on my show we did an
interview he freestyled
and steve was there and uh no you met
him before that
i don't remember then we sent you music
on him before that when he was in
arizona guy you
because i was like we was like he was
popping right there
yeah i listen you're getting old i i am
getting old
that's facts um but no but i was i was
gonna yo so a 10-year contract that's
crazy right
when you think of it right that's how it
was back then but you actually
yeah but let me tell you like this it
should never change
and this is the reason why because it's
one thing to be management
is one thing to be production if i'm
your production company you come to me
as a kid and you have nothing
and i create your name and i create you
and help to create you give you what you
want
how is there a number on how long i can
make money off of this
right because if i don't do that
what are you gonna do then what are you
gonna do right right cause you gotta
remember
before nip came to me he had already him
and his brother had already had a deal
where they had paid i can't remember to
do to distribute their music
he never did it that came back
i do think that there's a middle ground
there because i always
you'll notice artists will pop
and the people who who made it happen
for them sometimes get left behind you
know like
that's that's what i'm saying that
happened with cardi b you know uh there
was a guy named shaft who really
blew him exactly right
it's like you signed the paperwork and
what would happen if these people didn't
believe in you when they believed in you
you know what i'm saying so i only eat
for so long and then you go on to be
forever i put in the grunt work and now
now this shit's hot i mean i i mean it's
both ways it's i mean you know like and
you'll say 10 years we're goddamnit like
i'm only close eat for 10 years
but guess when you make it you really
most people don't make it to after five
six years
yeah the first the first four or five
years is no money coming in it's all
spending it's all money going out
exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah remember how
many people was grinding before that
mm-hmm you know and then so so example
like just say uh on nephew vincent neal
fensten
when i first got with nick nick was in
the hood
he had already been uh um to uh dre
nemmy already been a different people he
had tried to go on
he was they was knocking him down
because his music was too violent he was
a [ __ ]
and uh uh um he looked like snoop so
that was like how they ain't gonna work
you just wanna snoop
and so when i come i'm like okay i'm
gonna take
and we gonna re-cook this you understand
what i'm saying right
so now it's the same way with everybody
in this documentary
everybody in the documentary had the
same exact thing
cooking somebody being there putting
their money behind them
putting their name behind them saying
this is the one
and then boom you know what i'm saying
because you don't just get to walk
through the door
and say i'm here now i'm here now right
right right you know what i mean how
many people really did that
neil nyx um soldier boy
a couple of people the internet has kind
of changed i think the internet's
the variable that's made made it
possible for just some [ __ ] to go viral
and now you can't even do that now
because now there's so many people
paying they paying to get five million
views on youtube
you know a lot of paying to get this
spotify now you came in tick-tock
all that [ __ ] you can't pay you can't
even tell us something is really organic
that's some real [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying yeah so
it's like a lot of it is optics it's
like yo for somebody seriously
let's you know we got to make sure the
numbers on spotify i gotta have
someone googles my [ __ ] on spotify
there's gotta be a certain number of
monthly listeners and
now they give you a kit okay if you pay
1500
you'll get one thousand million views
for sure you get this you get that you
get this
but but what about me being able to say
look
kay can you do an interview on him me
being able to say vlad can you do an
interview on
me being able to say something such
getting you know what i mean
but what's the value on that oh the
values don't only get to ride for so
long
no bro like i don't think that's
business
being myself so i kind of moved out of
that and
went to doing i saw like i said when i
stopped doing nip
i started managing vain reigns i managed
rain rains
and i started doing shows so it made me
open up to dealing with more artists and
i wasn't dealing with one artist no more
i was doing shows so i was making more
money doing shows because i hadn't made
not one dime wouldn't it wow
you know what i'm saying i was i was
booking shows
of talent coming in and i'm making
fifteen twenty thousand dollars when the
artists land games
no then i was making way more way more
i'm making something you were talking
about just booking concerts
looking kind of like putting the bread
behind bringing some people out doing
the of my own concerts
getting numbers i might have i might
highlight wiz like where's
what's your number for booking yeah and
then look i'm gonna put ten thousand on
it
or what's your number for this i'm gonna
put five thousand on it and he like okay
okay you get my number up that high
and so what people to never understand
is i never cut an artist's number
ever i've never cut an artist's number
for nothing only for radio shows
because radios you do different yeah
it's different every artist i ever met
and ever did business with me they'd
give me a number and um
tell me what their number is i'm gonna
get the deal higher than that because i
know the promoters who are gonna really
pay
and that's the relationship you want
with big u because i'm gonna make sure
you get paid your money
when when when the migos came i had the
amigos book
for three shows at 15 000 a piece
danny glover goes on the grammys
and they ask him what is he listening to
he says
i'm listening to the me bad and boujee
yeah bad and booze yep it was over after
that
and yeah the number went from 15
000 to 100 yeah i remember i was trying
to book them at that time
yeah i'm aware but i was the only one
who they was led booking them because i
had a relationship with them through
atlanta from that level
right you know what i mean so and and
that's what
that's what that's what you know we do
as power brokers in this in this
industry
it ain't it ain't violence it ain't you
know what ain't the [ __ ] but i might
know the promoter you don't want to deal
with
right i might know the promoter who who
ain't going to pay you
i might know look you don't want to
charge radio
you want to do this no you don't want to
take 30 of your homeboys to this concert
and backstage
and y'all risked it and getting into
with somebody aeg
right you get into with a g you can't
play no concerts around yeah you're
[ __ ]
that's what we've done for sure yo what
up taking a break in
into the uh the bootleg head podcast
here to tell you about our sponsor odd
socks man make sure you go tap in with
oddssoxofficial.com
look i got [ __ ] odd socks on right
now you know what i'm saying got the
macho man randy savages
you know uh look they got the most
comfortable socks i ever put on my feet
not only that but they got the crazy
licenses they got the wwe
how about these scarface joints these
joints are crazy man
so scarface breaking bad um and their
odd socks basics line
these joints are so comfortable so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg cav save 20 at
checkout
plus they just drop underwear on them
plus they just drop them slippers
and they got the mass oddsoxofficial.com
keyword bootleg
cab at checkout save 20 off [ __ ] with
odd socks
you know your initial deal with nipsey
was 10 years and how sometimes
artists you know
that sounds crazy but if you really
think about the position that some the
early people who get in on artists
you know put them in is it seems fair
because like
you were saying the first four or five
years really no money coming in right
no money it's all your money going out
that's what a production company
is facts so um let me tell you the thing
about nipsey
what what i like about nip it's not what
we did to help nipsey
to start nc it's what nipsey continued
to do
after he was gone that's what separates
nipsey you know what i mean
because we was all negative for for a
run
you know what i'm saying but bro he kept
going you know i mean i left
i i went to go do it was nip and steve
if you see
i i left i didn't get fired i never got
fired i left after
uh my house got hit while they was on
tour on the las tour
and i left music and i talked about in
the documentary
so nobody fired me i left my own self
and i started just doing football and
managing vain reigns
so i was making i was making it was no
money on the music
but i started making then at 200 some
thousand dollars here just managing
veeam reigns right and just doing movies
and i was doing that
doing shows the ones and i started doing
shows so i was dealing with
every artist not just
not just one artist and so
i was successful doing that and i
continue up into the covert to make
money
booking shows and putting on concerts
doing so
i do one concert a year for developing
options for the kids
and then all throughout the year i do
other concerts for myself so
i've always made money and i made way
more money
than i ever did um dealing with one
artist
right with respect to my my kid and so
um that's what i've i've i've never had
not had a shortcoming
all my cards are paid for my house
everything right you know what i mean so
i've done real well and i've been doing
well
i'm not dealing with one artist until
nip called me
after he signed with atlantic and he was
like uh
unk i signed with atlantic numbers that
right you're like mom we finna go
and his thing was i mean we got to do
what uh kendrick and um top did
we got to redo we gotta do it right and
he was asking me to come back and manage
and i'm like
[ __ ] man i don't want to get back in the
rook and move you know what i'm saying
he's like nah
man and i said so what's the situation
he's like you still got the contract
it ain't you you gonna do what you want
to do so i'm like
was really in your hands yeah yeah so
but you know we always had that love
i always support him in the hood he
always supported me in the hood and uh
even after we had the conflict and so
when
when he got ready to go to new york he
he bought me a ticket well he paid for
me a tee to go to new york
and the ticket was was me and robin the
ticket was a problem with that so we
ended up paying for ourselves
we did the video in new york we came
back to do some stuff out here
and as you can see i'm all over the um
victory lap we promoting it
and um but we uh we uh
i was in a studio with him for
four days recording just recording
vocals talking about him and how he came
about first time he wanted me to just
tell him all the different stories and
stories of prison
so we did that and i got when i posted
up when me and he was in the studio
we've
been there all night and i did all that
right before victory lap because he was
going to drop him he's gonna drop vicky
lap then he's gonna come right back with
a mixtape
on that and so now you kind of narrated
yeah yeah and i read the whole tape
like just telling the hood stories and
all that coming on
and i really don't know where that is
now we did it at pmr studio i
ran into a kid who did the recording for
us oh the engineer yeah
engineer and he's like what happened to
all that yeah yeah nice said they
gathered it right right
the the family and all that got it so i
don't know you know what they ever do
because our relationships ain't what it
is
you're um you mentioned the conflict
there was a obviously a
a widely known uh incident that had
happened
um what was the uh when you guys did
have your
your your outs before everything got
reconciled what was the uh
the root of that well when we first
started
it goes back to our recording equipment
i had a deal with tiny lister
me tiny lister and a tiny list of friend
he was i can't
i don't want to i wasn't so bad with
names remember his name he we did a deal
that we were going to sign nip and he
purchased the equipment for us
and we was a we said sunset we present
we present equipment and that's where
nipsey was staying with me sammy went to
jail
and nipsey was staying in my uh condo in
hawthorne
and we had the equipment set up there we
was recording so this is the equipment
that nipsey had recorded on and was
recording on the whole time right
and so once we had went our different
ways
we i wanted to use the equipment when i
decided to come back because this other
kid
but where nissi had the equipment was in
the downtown studio
and you could only get there at night
or you couldn't go in after 10 o'clock
or they were penalized i'm like bro
let's just move it on 43rd
because i had a place in 43rd and he was
cool with that but then
it was conflict in the hood between him
and some of
the other little times and i can't go
into that i won't ever go into that
question i don't know it so
you know what i mean if you and so then
it kind of like
went bad and he made a diss song i asked
him about it
came to check him about it we went to go
pick him up
he was 100 hood with it nip always good
100
for sure for sure and then the conflict
happened
um it was some some rough rule rugged
rules you know what i'm saying
and we all went to jail and that night
nip didn't go to jail
just me and his brother and a couple
homes went to jail we got out that night
nip called me
i met nip the next night i met nip and
sam the next night at the african
restaurant on um
fairfax the very next night
like like after after
whatever had happened um
sam had the bill out two days later or
something like that we all met
before that we met we met that night at
at um on fairfax african restaurant
because it was used to go yeah and uh
it was basically like that it was it so
it was just yeah because i mean that hit
hike all hip-hop yeah
all the different which he was supposed
to do and i mean and when he ran witty
he like uh i feel to put some songs out
i'm
man go ahead do what you're going to do
wow because if it was a conflict
it would've never stopped there right
it's like the next day you guys win the
eight yeah it couldn't have never been a
continued conflict right
how could that we still here yeah it
couldn't have never been a continued
conflict
or it would have been a continued
conference right you know what i'm
saying like he's
he's he's my baby he not even
five generations under me i'm i'm
like the beginning and nip is a baby in
our industry and where are we from
you know what i mean like he ain't even
you know what i'm saying like he got to
getting there
as he got more popular in the world but
at that time he still was a baby
yo i wanted to ask you because someone
like nip like i feel like
is you mentioned earlier kind of the
diamond in the rough right
yeah not everybody has the the state of
mind that he he had
that not at all you know the way that he
did everything with
purpose and intention you know like was
he always like that did you kind of know
that about him
from like the whole time i really kind
of think he got that from his family
like his brother
um um they they
are real driven like they are real
driven people you know what i'm saying
like
um they move with a purpose right
i move with a purpose it's very few
people who move with a purpose
and he moved with a purpose you know and
you can see it you know how you go
around somebody and you can see that
this dude
when it's time to film he's always here
he always got the camera yeah
you can see that this is what he won't
do nip didn't have no back door he
didn't have no
no um no second plan this was it this
music
this is what it was and it was it yeah
what it what no i'm gonna be a lawyer or
doctor if this don't work
this is it yo he passed away and then
you had organized or helped organize
like it was like
a day of unity in your neighborhood that
um you know i really wasn't aware of
like the historical context of the head
had to break it down to me because yeah
because you know i'm not fully tapped in
with all the politics and who's this and
you know what i'm saying that was good
and so he was kind of explaining to me
like the i
the fact that these people and these
people are together
was so big like talk about that day
and and and why that was such a big deal
shouts out um um the little home girl
from the jungles um
you're bad with names let's say that
just so so they don't get mad yeah yeah
anyway a.d uh skip um
the little home girl from the jungles
she's a beautiful person i can't say her
name i don't know why i got a name
but anyway they were the ones who
orchestrated it and even before we did
the walk we were already
talking about you know ways to because i
do gang intervention
to stop the violence amongst our people
so
they wanted to do the walk and i was
like yeah it's a good idea to do it
but when they were calling people to
come and saying it was cool
most of the people were saying hell no
we're not coming unless big you say it's
cool to come
and that's when i went on there and said
everybody's welcome to come i was
hurting at that time
you know what i mean of course that was
right after an ipad pass
days later it was days later and
i i was i was hurting and
it was crazy because my whole family was
hurting my kids was hurting because
they know nancy they know nipsey from
coming to sleep at our house
he lived in our house 103rd um and then
when he got his check that's
when he you know he graduated from there
and he was like a brother he was like a
big brother to my my daughter right
in my 14 year old and he was a big
brother to my to my son
my 21 years in college he posted him all
the time so
it was crazy that it happened
but the unity walk was
so necessary because he had reached
such a different pinnacle in l.a
with all gangs that dudes from every set
want to come pay respect
you know what i mean and we wanted to
you wanted to facilitate that you know
what i mean and it was so beautiful man
and i'm so glad that i was just a part
of it
and i was able to to make that happen
because that was great for l.a man that
was great
for our souls you know what i mean right
to see some dudes we had been fighting
with for years
yeah cause like like you know like
is it almost take an event like that to
happen
not i'm not specifically talking about
nip's death but something of that
magnitude
to happen to kind of because you know
it's hard to tell someone to stop
going to war with somebody if their
uncle died or their
brother died yeah man because it was a
lot of backlash
on our side it was backlash on our side
other gang size you know because dudes
who still like you said should
feel a certain way so it was it was a
call that was made
and people came and they still had to go
back and like man with these dudes or
enemies still
so you know and with understanding that
that people lost fathers
uncles cousins yeah you know you got to
respect that but
that day showed that we could find a way
out
and that was our mission when we first
started with nick she ought to take you
back to that
and the reason why a lot of gangs
respected him because we made sure i
made sure we didn't diss nobody
in the beginning of his music i went
through all the videos watched all the
video i saw the signs in the world
no blob that out no signs this anymore i
made sure my homies didn't put up
nothing disrespecting nobody
if you look at them videos that was all
me mm-hmm you know what i'm saying
and then of course nip grew into that of
course because his first music was
rolling sixties brothers and girls and
you know
and we cleaned all that up you know i
mean and
you know it's all history now man
yo is it true that debo from friday was
inspired by you
was that character inspired by you no no
okay let me tell you how that went okay
this is the honest to god true if you're
going to get this here
i manage devo okay r.i.p
my big brother yeah man is devo and i
managed veeam he was one of the peoples
right
so to keep it 100 devo knew of big u
okay and he knew of my reputation like
everybody else
did and knew of my reputation but the
character
is written on one of the homies from
111.
that has nothing to do with me okay you
know what i'm saying whatsoever
i ain't never been in the hundreds you
know what i mean i i wrote a beast
cruiser but i ain't do that
i think i want to take it underneath so
you was riding around on the beach
cruiser like yeah we all ruined
roads but
i mean i wouldn't ride in the
neighborhoods and that's no change that
was kind of like some other [ __ ]
but dawg looks like folklore that that
was like based on
maybe debo like like knew of you and
like maybe no he knew of me yeah like
like he knew of me and but my you gotta
understand
my reputation goes back
to like 80 to like 80 80-81-82
right because you you're in jail when
friday comes out
yeah friday come on 95 yeah i was gone
yeah
i was going but my my my name and
reputation
was still pre-season of course of course
of course you know what i mean it
precedes that
but there were a lot of big big i mean
devos and
whatever right now tiny being the actor
that he was
could draw off a big u
and that's what he meant he meant that
he drew from the big u
to act that character got you guys not
did that character it wasn't written
after you yeah not at all
not at all because no i wasn't on no
bite
pushing up on no [ __ ]
so what year would wou would you say you
became
quote unquote rolling 60s like what year
was that i'm don't have no tattoos oh
that's fair
yeah what are we talking about i mean
just to be honest like i always say it
like this
i never became rolling 60s i think
roller cities became us
well you said it uh it's it's in you it
ain't on you
it's inuit ain't on you and i've been
saying that since the beginning of time
that's why i don't have
no tattoos so i used to say that years
ago because like we ain't got no tattoos
why i need them
that's some reason you don't know who i
am that's some real [ __ ] it ain't it
ain't
ain't on you it's in you so when dudes
used to get tattoos i was like [ __ ] oh
you had to put it on you to know it was
real
that's crazy they need it and that
what's crazy too is you got you came out
of jail with no tattoos no tattoos
i'm gonna say it again yep you know what
i'm saying it ain't on you
yeah then you you did was it true that
you got like
like like when you had to go like move
out of town and like you were in chicago
yeah we got kicked out you got kicked
out of l.a got kicked out of you
so what happened like how do you get
kicked out of a city well i said
something in the documentary because i
couldn't say what it really was
but i just said one part of what it was
there was the robberies but it was a lot
more
you know what i mean and so at that time
there was like either you can go to the
army or you can go to woo
and then it was like no i ain't doing an
army but i didn't have a choice either
but they couldn't find me guilty of a
lot of stuff i was been accused of
so they sent me
to go live with my father in chicago
okay
so i stayed up there until i turned 18
and then i came back so so you because
at the time you're a minor
so you're a minor so they can kind of
tell you like yo these are your options
you got to go here you got to do this
you got to do this
and that's what people don't understand
that when you are born in a state and
you get that birth certificate you're
actually the ward of the state you don't
actually bond to your parents
until they actually go to court and file
to get you on
to become your guardian that's so crazy
yeah you actually
belong to the state so they got to tell
you like hey these are your options
you can't be here no judge will go in
front of you and tell you
we can send this you here that's how
they able to sentence you in court
damn yeah how did you start to get
involved in coaching
like in the football stuff because i
feel like for the people who've been
paying attention to the last decade i
feel like
you're up you know since you've been
home i feel like you've been a pillar of
the community but
specifically when it comes to coaching
and and being involved in the youth
football alan long man
alan long aka big ad was the first one i
coached when i came home his father and
mother
always had a football program okay so
they always did that
and then along with my homeboys big d f
going on who was coaching their sons
while i was in prison
and then when i came home they um was
doing it so and my son
my sons were good athletes really good
athletes always to hear about
how good they were so when i came home i
just wanted to get in there and sit back
and kind of sit in the
in the cut and and work with them and i
started developing well i started extra
finished fellowship network
which is the parent company of
developing options before i actually
came home
and that goes to my stepfather who's
donald ray evan
and he's always been conscious he's
always had me read books and all that
stuff he's been really conscious
so when i made the change and i was
making a change
he just kept reinforcing me with books
and helping me
and he helped me start executing his
fellowship network while i was in prison
so then i changed the name to develop an
option
because there was some people like it so
developing options not actually the
non-profit extra fitness fellowship
network is the non-profit
we just do business as development
options for stealing and security
purposes people can
steal and do things so but then it took
me into
to to want to do something for our
community man i wanted to give back
i wanted to to really be able to
see these kids making it and not have to
go through what i went through because i
didn't handle father
all right i ain't really had nobody who
was telling us like don't do this do
that
you know you can make it i didn't have
that you know it was like go hustle
get the grind on that's how the family
was i ain't have nobody saying
you can make it in school i never had
that yeah and you've had like
players that you've coached like get
drafted and and all that man which is
eight eight nine just made it to the
league that i've coached
i have um maybe
about 1500 through college
which is even that's if that might even
be a bigger deal
oh that is a big that's you know fifteen
hundred kids just going to college
yeah yeah yeah and i got um
my son my son's my last coach my last
class of kids is in this documentary
and it's eight of them and uh
four graduate this year from college and
then
six graduate next year from college
wow talk about that that's crazy
yeah that's mine that's the work i got
that's the crenshaw way and they all
went to crenshaw high school
believe that wow yeah so my usually my
program takes kids from my program
the christian rams crenshaw coast and
then into
crenshaw high school and then from their
college and um
like i said that last group i got ucla
dixie state u.s navy um
reno nevada um
georgia um
um miami
and i don't know cussed out yo how did
you become
you're a vikings fan right oh yeah i got
but how the hell did you become a
vikings fan
i got more money out of minnesota than i
ever got in any other state
okay okay i was like i was seeing that
i'm like yo
how did how did you become a vikings fan
that's so great that lady had no
football team
okay who do you go to i went to the soda
all right we had no football with rams
left raiders coming going and he was
like [ __ ]
i went purple i meant and then to this
day
first property i ever bought in my name
not in my name
my i bought it another day but first
probably everybody brought out here
first thing i ever you know like so
minnesota is important to your story
obviously it was important i ain't never
been back either since they ran me out
of there
that's crazy wait wait why'd you get ran
out of minnesota what happened
i never been back since then yeah what
if that what if like
hypothetically speaking the super bowls
in minnesota and the vikings happened to
make it to the super bowl that same year
like the bucks just did in tampa
we might just drive another state okay
you mentioned um you know reading some
books what are what
what are like three or four books that
have changed your life malcolm x
autobiography
um rich dad poor dad
visions for black men and on the bronzer
files by joey browner
okay is easy how about this as like a 13
year old white kid i read the
autobiography of malcolm x
crazy made me cut my hair i didn't even
realize mal
as a kid like i didn't you know i
learned about malcolm x from hip hop and
[ __ ]
i didn't realize he was on some gangster
[ __ ] like detroit red was like
that [ __ ] you know i didn't like
that movie i didn't like the
i i liked the concept of the movie i
didn't see the movie you didn't see the
movie i just just came out
um um you tell me the one that came out
on amazon prime
the night of miami one night in miami i
haven't seen it i kind of feel like they
made my man
too weak undecisive in his life
how's your relationship with farrakhan
what
that's pops love fair kind of death what
do you think is
i feel like there's so many
misconceptions about no misconception
it ain't no misconception he has done he
has done nothing but
good for our people is no misconception
only way you can find something wrong
with him is you looking to find
something wrong with him
and i won't even let nobody say it's a
misconception for somebody who was all
his life fought for our life
right right right like if you can find
something wrong with him
then you can find something wrong with
us as a people that's fair it's black
people you got a problem with black
people because he's never done nothing
but fought for us
period and when you were you said when
you were locked up
like he was like you you would almost
stay like frowned upon the fact that you
had a relationship with him
yeah no they was trying to um they
sentenced me that was one of the
sentences one of my um
my uh aggravated aggravating
circumstances
that um i had a relationship that i had
a relationship with him that's [ __ ]
crazy
yeah it was in my transfers too that's
why but
you know i think though even like my
situation right now
because as this documentary go i still
hear where the feds is going to ask
people like
what can you give us on big u like what
do you know about big u what is this and
in light of the the um in light of
what's going on in the capital and
them rushing the capital it's crazy that
i still get calls from people that's
imprisoned and saying that
they come in and ask them what can you
what can you give us on big u like i've
been home 17
16 years i do gang intervention and
i have to have a relationship with gang
members to do gang intervention to help
your community if i don't have a
relationship with gang members how can i
call
a thousand gang members to be able to
come to this nipsey thing
you know what i'm saying but i am still
being pursued to this day right now
i got a call not too long ago tell them
some of my partners saying that they was
asking what can they
give them we can help you like how are
you looking for something like i thought
the
the fact of crime was let's catch him
doing what he doing
and not going back looking for something
30 40 years ago because they trying to
do a recoil from my understanding on the
hood
so i got to be scared to say if i'm even
affiliated with the hood wow
you understand what i'm saying like we
got to be careful of what you say now
but this is what you looking for like
and you see them
doing this stuff but it goes back to
what malcolm
and martin was talking about they killed
all of our black leaders
or their sinuses in some kind of way why
if they feel like you got a big voice so
i guess there's a time period on how
long big you last
because it's something to come up would
you ever become a part of the political
process
i'm a part of the political process i
mean as far as like being you know
running for any sort of official
i wouldn't run for no office but i'm
running for office right now
like just being a voice for our people
just a level voice
and and like they said like diego hoover
said the um the fear of the white man is
is the intelligence of a black man that
[ __ ] real
like it's real and i and i'm not capping
at you
no no i listen bro tell you what's
really going on right now today that's
100
like you said yo what what happened the
capital [ __ ] was to me the biggest like
example of like
all of that energy should it be on these
on these white boys how are you still
finding where they at
how are you still pursuing black men who
ain't got no power in this country
literally infiltrated and can't do
nothing like even if we wanted to if you
organize every black man in this country
we couldn't do [ __ ]
i mean just to be honest we can't take
over [ __ ] we ain't gonna move on nothing
we ain't the problem in america when do
they figure that [ __ ] out
we not the problem i don't disagree man
listen i do not disagree
it's been it's been a crazy uh been a
crazy last four years
a lot of [ __ ] have been
emboldened you know what i'm saying if
anything at least it made people like
i think trump being president people
actually like were at least brave enough
to show you who they were right
you know what i'm saying but just to be
on another note on the trump note
uh it's some dumb white people
oh for sure like for real though bro
like
and i don't want to disrespect nobody
but hey i don't get it i used to think
you know coming up it's the white world
white police white school officers
i mean white teachers white police white
judges white
superman white wonder woman white
everything was just the word i grew up
in
right well none black on tv but sammy
davis jr and he claimed to be a jew
so we ain't had [ __ ] but black
exploitation films that came out
and they was all taking cocaine shooting
right through some kind of jewelry some
gangster
yeah you're saying so you get to think
that
but when trump came trump unveiled a
whole different people
now they always been there some of you
they're called
yeah i will but i'm gonna just say i'm
gonna just say
there's white trash the intelligence
level is
is far different than i thought like oh
no there listen man
there's a whole middle part of the
america where
these [ __ ] are real just
they're just
they're they're like truly brainwashed
people
right i was like it's crazy it's crazy
and then i like trump for a different
reason
what was your reason for that because he
was a hustler and and and
watch this when i was gone
trump was the hip-hop being for sure oh
no
he was doing like skits on
methamphetamine albums and all kinds of
[ __ ] yeah yeah
everything was about i read trump book
bro he was yeah
and he's also a life-long democrat his
whole his whole entire life
and then he flipped the script you know
why get the bag because he knew how
stupid
people were these white people were he's
like i know exactly how to get these
fools i'ma just shoot up this fear right
into their arm
talk about every other race yeah and and
i mean it worked for i mean it the jig
is up obviously but
it got him elected dude to the highest
office
dude flip the whole script how you going
from on yachts and snooping
and my bed was a cold businessman and he
just dived in on the other [ __ ] oh
man no no definitely you know i'm not
even sure as a businessman
he's as cold as we i think that might be
a little bit inflated as well
nah well see the thing about it is trump
didn't do business to do business trump
did
trump did business to get some money
when you when you're building a business
you're like me and you you ground as
your baby you
you hustling at it every single day
trump did corporations i thought i read
his book
compass trump established corporations
to make
two 300 150 million and then debunk the
corporations once you get everybody an
investment oh yeah i hear what you're
saying so
he wasn't in it for good business he was
in it for money he was going to get to
bring that's fair
you know what i mean he wasn't in it to
make rs studios become like the biggest
uh um studio in the world how
but right now i'm getting this back
um can you obviously you you know we got
osbs who's here in the building but
talk about just before we wrap up man
like what you have going on obviously
i got a i got a talk show coming out
like this from the podcast called
checking
in oh yes sir i like that
perfect name check it in with big you
you did
so there's gonna be a podcast on the way
podcast it's coming right now man we're
doing it right now
and uh i gotta just i'm so now i'm doing
distribution
so unique entertainment is now we're a
distribution company like uh
empire um um distro kids so
kids can go upload their music and
they're not signing to us they're just
going through us as a platform
to get to music you're helping them get
their music from music out yeah and then
if somebody blows we're gonna definitely
want to reach out to you
you know together but it's um you'll be
able to sign up online
we're going to start promoting and
pushing that you know really i'm just
looking at it like that just doing
distribution
and that's no contract that's just you
can go in
you only you don't have to do a contract
as far as the music you're uploading
make sure you ain't stole nobody's
beating
right right right right right cause then
you guys yeah yeah nobody's signing to
us
unless they choose to or we listen to
your music but they'll be able to upload
their music
and put their videos up and the music
just goes from there and they'll be able
to download it
get paid um i think our payout is like
in three days
of whatever they make oh wow that's fast
yeah we're not doing
we're not doing no 50 50. we you know we
it's majority money goes to them and
again it's nobody signing to us it's
gonna be able to
load their music get it out and
work it would um how like
i think with i mean obviously i'm sure
there's already been some interest but
with this show coming out i'm sure
there's gonna be a lot of interest
for like the rights to your story doing
a movie
like i said where actor plays you has
there been any sort of discussion
for some [ __ ] like that yeah i had a
deal actually on the table man with
veeam rains
about five years ago was he gonna was he
gonna be the one to play
yeah well he was supposed to play me
then you know him and titan he was lobby
you know who was gonna do it right
so it was crazy you know but uh we just
never pulled the trigger
uh my boss my wife was just satisfied i
like how you call
your wife your boss too because i feel
you yeah my boss she's my boss too man
she was like uh no she don't like it
oh she didn't like the script because in
the script
and the script i had to be like the
protagonist they wanted me to be mean
towards her
and they wanted to be she was like you
ain't never hit me and i'm like baby
it's just it's just for like
the movie and she like i ain't scared of
you why they got me why i gotta be
scared i'm like
don't worry about it it's not gonna come
out yeah like because then
she's like [ __ ] i [ __ ] you up and she
like
she like she like and so you know the
lady who wrote it
she was like no we gotta wanna make him
be like you know and then he had
because it shows that evolution she like
would make him be mean to somebody else
and i'm like look like
it's is they telling the story yeah you
know what i mean she was like hell no
did you are you are you a fan of have
you have you checked out the show um
snowfall
on fx yeah i watched it yes
i didn't watch all of it i mean i've
dimmed in it because people always tell
me about what you're about to say
yeah i just didn't like i i was just
curious to see if like how
how accurate you thought they kind of
depicted that era
i don't know i didn't even look at it to
see if it was accurate
uh because it's a good ass show and uh
everyone says that it's
loosely based on freeway ricky ross but
i'm not that i feel like it was based
off of bo
bennett okay um i don't know
from what i seen because when i heard
about the story he got on in the valley
that's how bo got on in the valley yeah
yeah he got on in the valley yeah and it
came me up
freeway got on i don't know
i think he was always in the hood
because you know we all we all know each
other we all are good friends
so when i heard there was a valley story
and i seen some of it i'm like that's bo
bo went to school and
beau lived in on florence and and he
went to school in the valley
and and kind of got on and i didn't ever
know freeway because i thought freeway
kind of moved out here when he was kind
of like
16 or 17 like and he didn't do no more
he didn't do no schooling
this kid was kind of in the in the
snowfall is supposed to be kind of smart
right
yeah he's smart kid for sure yeah yeah
it's a great show i just didn't know
because i know that was kind of your
error so i didn't know
that was my hair that's definitely my
hair definitely yeah it's definitely my
hair
yes it's check that [ __ ] out but you
gotta like really watch like you can't
just get in and out of it you gotta like
bang out all three seasons i'm now gonna
watch the whole season because we're on
on fx
yeah hip hop uncovered on fx
and it's hey two episodes dropping every
friday right every friday every friday
total of six so the next three fridays
and then if you got the fx app
go get that yeah go get the fx no go get
the hulu app
yeah because it's streaming it's on hulu
yeah it's streaming on hulu
but it's airing on fx so listen i know
you got the calls running man listen i
appreciate you coming through and thank
you for the discussion man and um
and going to the rs studios you already
know looking
you know he for whatever reason you know
he he happens to be fond of those
initials
[Laughter]
big you thank you bro perfect that was
dope man thanks brother